hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to totally accurate
battle simulator there has been a lot of
additions it's now pre alpha zero point
two point zero and with it comes new
Maps estimated performance and also
those really weird mysterious chicken
men and then a chicken man man which I
don't know what that means
I'm assuming it's a chicken that spits
out little men let's test that theory I
actually haven't used it before I'm not
lying
I've never used this never seen it
that's my guess
I hope there's gonna be correct and I'm
gonna put a smaller chicken man on the
oh that's not small at all but I okay
it's chicken man for this chicken man
man chicken man for chicken man man hope
it's a giant one too always giant oh yes
I wasn't Spencer chicken man Oh God
I'm Way too excited about that that is
all so cool oh that's so cool oh god I'm
Way too excited about this right off the
bat I love that I love it I love it not
only cost 5,000 how would anybody be
able to beat that holy [ __ ] there's been
other things added to the game too like
more levels that we can do up to level
20 I believe I don't even think it was
up to level 10 before but now there's
too much to play around with and I'm
gonna have a good old time with the
chicken man man and then maybe do the
story mode after that because holy [ __ ]
chicken man man gonna be over there and
then it's gonna be I'm gonna I'm gonna
have ever-increasing people to try to
stop it good Oh estimated performance is
gonna be bad
like hell it is look at my coffee ooh
those are nice organized beeps over
there what you'll never stop the chicken
oh oh that's so adorable hey hey dude
hey dude hey dude how you doing dude oh
you look so good where he always coming
after me Oh God he's seen me he spotted
me I think he actually has holy [ __ ] oh
no not another pass Oh God
someone save us from this hell I mean
there's still alive front for now oh
Jesus and chickens okay
well that didn't work oh that didn't
work
it's just ballet chicken he's doing the
can-can just because he can that's that
didn't work I'm gonna get my my boxer
buddies here these boxes ain't gonna
stop me we know what's up don't we gents
come on stop pressing up against each
other
there's no defense there you got a face
or head on all the way oh god he poops
him out his butt Oh God that's directly
out the blood oh yes Oh strut your do
off huh boink oh and they're fine did
you know that when the chicken man is
birth it's mature enough to walk on two
legs I have a feeling that we're just
gonna have a problem but if there's one
thing I know that can tame us some
chickens it's gonna be farmers go for it
get that performance look at my copy
it's so good it's so big just like it I
don't know I hope I get um ah
oh I don't quite know how to hold this
but okay here we go oh [ __ ] dude he
looks big
farmers tame your wild stock they're not
even coming towards you Oh chickens yeah
you better run away
oh no this guy's gonna be a hero don't
do it oh [ __ ]
well he's dead well I don't think
anything is gonna be able to beat this
[ __ ] maybe just maybe archers not
poachers poachers would be why they long
why are they long that doesn't make any
sense
go get them po cheese the poachers go
make a good number you got down there
chickens deer you think your chickens
gonna match anything against our barrage
of toothpicks ha your ankles are gonna
be devastated just like your willpower
oh jeez he's gonna have a tough time
walking after that just like oh this
connects with arrows in their backs ah
and for the shin it's his weak point
preferably aim for the giant gaping
butthole in the back it's like the
exhaust port on the Death Star if you
had a bull's eye how about the noble
samurai I'm sure that this is gonna go
swimmingly
all right samurai go get him okay
there's gonna there's gonna be good this
is gonna be good you don't have any
further Oh Oh get stabbed in those
ankles oh I didn't think anything was
gonna beat that I should have done that
in Japan all right well if you can take
on one chicken man man surely three
shan't be a problem oh oh it's so nice
oh yes cross the river
oh this beautiful oh this oh that's
terrifying actually I take that back
that's horrifying you're killing your
own dudes oh geez this this might
actually be a problem this might
actually be a problem
Hey this was scary only 100 he can't be
stopped
okay so what can stop this samurai
besides themselves this is the thing in
numbers you know I think it's a quantity
versus quality type deal so I'm gonna
just see how many chicken men men can
withstand the honorable and noble
samurai we're gonna do this in the
middle winter I think that's an elegant
backdrop for this tactic
I think it's an elegant backdrop for
this tact we're gonna penetrate your
defenses we're coming for you don't
worry about a thing we're gonna ran
through your dough that guy did
Oh gets tube him oh geez
oh it's too many what's too many it's
too many now they're who stood Vikings
so we're going to get the Vikings the
Vikings are coming forget here our
County Vikings I know this isn't how the
Vikings talks let me have some fun we're
coming for ya I'm good to ask you in the
ankle hold Acharya birthing happy finish
Norman what's that
oh I'm incredibly offensive are you sure
not annoying oh that too oh well can I
keep doing it I shouldn't
mmm
now I'm gonna keep doing it a fear and
tearing of thärning who's the old God so
I'm not done with the chicken man
man we're gonna do like legit archers
not these namby-pamby poachers we're
gonna get legit archers here hi oh my
god they're already smarter cuz they're
not aiming for the ankles
furgus yearning burdened is your burger
mcdougal we think I'm a balls are they
aiming exclusively for the crotchal
region I feel bad for the Jets oh they
caught one holy crap
they got one I am shocked
oh alright so what's gonna happen here
is its its quantity thing so I'm gonna
reduce it down to just two chicken women
three actually but they're all gonna be
in a line and then I'm gonna get even
more archers my performance gonna be so
bad you're ready for lag oh this is too
much lag all right go for it get him get
a man get a man oh he's too far away oh
god don't fire till you see the whites
of his eyes
what's hit Oh then fire you [ __ ] okay I
wanna know if it would even be possible
to kill it with like war machines yet
bliss duggan watches in the back watches
in the back your room okay so we got a
lot so this shouldn't go to bachas what
are you doing oh my god
be careful are you ready buddy all right
are you gonna be ready for this when the
time comes and the time to strike
arrives
was you burned off where are you firing
oh oh oh hey Fred you okay you are a
friend you don't look so good
I think Fred's dead well they didn't get
a one of them they didn't get a one once
again we got the everlasting Melissa
he's he's got chickens caught up in his
firing mechanism Oh
oh they got one right at the end there I
think he gave up him Eddie now the only
question remains there's only one
question on my mind how many chicken men
men does it take to kill one chicken man
men I could be better all right so we
got 36 chicken women or 36 chicken men
versus one chicken man
we're gonna have an ass load of chickens
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness yeah you better run away
because you are in trouble
holy [ __ ] bone
oh god what is happening oh god what is
yeah I think holy [ __ ] we alright we've
answered that puzzle okay so that was at
least one of the new additions to
totally accurate battle simulator the
other being there's more levels so if
you want to see me go through the levels
again and probably face up against
another chicken man man let me do it on
the comments below other than that thank
you so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]